digamos que quieres resolver esta
ecuación 2 elevado a la equis cuadrada
menos 3 es igual a 1 entre la raíz
cúbica de x pausa el vídeo e intenta
encontrar la respuesta probablemente te
diste cuenta que esta ecuación no es
nada sencilla de resolver la forma de
intentar resolverla es primero escribir
2 elevado a la equis cuadrada menos 3 es
igual a equis a la y del lado derecho
voy a escribir uno entre raíz cúbica de
x como x elevado a la menos un tercio
tal vez pueda simplificar al elevar
ambos lados a la potencia menos 3 y con
eso obtendría que si elevó un exponente
a otro exponente puedo multiplicar los
exponentes por lo tanto me quedara
los elevado a la menos 3x cuadrada más 9
sólo multiplique ambos términos por este
exponente menos 3 es igual a x elevado a
la menos un tercio elevado a la menos 3
bueno menos un tercio por menos 3 es
simplemente uno por lo tanto me quedaré
solo con x
esto parece un poco más simple pero
sigue sin ser fácil puedo intentar
aplicar la función logaritmo en base 2
de ambos lados y me quedaría con menos 3
x cuadrada más 9 es igual al logaritmo
en base 2 de x pero una vez más no es
fácil resolver esto la razón del por qué
te doy esta ecuación es que apreciamos
que existen algunas ecuaciones que no
son sencillas se resuelven de manera
algebraica pero tenemos otras
herramientas como computadoras podemos
graficar y al menos con ellas podemos
acercarnos mucho a la solución de la
ecuación la forma de hacerlo es definir
una función que sea que es igual
2 elevado a la equis cuadrada menos 3 y
definir otra función que sea ye igual a
1 entre la raíz cúbica de x después
graficar ambas funciones y observar
donde se intersectan porque donde se
intersectan significa que jim la función
2 elevado a la x cuadrada menos 3 te da
la misma james que 1 entre la raíz
cúbica de x u otra forma de pensarlo es
que se intersectan en un valor x donde
estas dos expresiones son iguales entre
sí entonces lo que podemos hacer es
utilizar una calculadora gráfica o ir a
un sitio web como test mos graficar las
y al menos intentar aproximar el punto
de intersección así que vamos a hacerlo
antes de empezar el vídeo fui a des
mosses y grafica estas funciones puedes
ver que tenemos nuestros dos lados de la
ecuación
ahora he expresado cada uno de ellos
como una función en color azul tengo la
función ye igual a efe x que es igual a
2 elevado a la x cuadrada menos 3 y por
otra parte tengo la función amarillenta
quien iguala de x que es igual a 1 entre
la raíz cúbica de x y podemos ver donde
se intersectan se intersectan aquí
aunque no vamos a obtener una respuesta
exacta pero incluso en este nivel de
acercamiento y en una herramienta como
decimos puedes acercarte más de forma
que obtengas una respuesta más y más
precisa de hecho puedes desplazarte
sobre este punto y te dirá dónde se
intersectan pero incluso si observamos
esta gráfica podemos intentar
aproximarnos a la respuesta podemos ver
que el valor de x parece ser
aproximadamente
bueno si acá tenemos 1.5 y cada uno
textos es un décimo entonces por acá
tenemos a 1.6 y después avanzamos dos
tercios de otro décimo así que parece
ser aproximadamente 1.66 y si fueras a
encontrar la solución exacta en realidad
la encontrarás muy cerca de 1.66 el
punto importante de todo esto es que
incluso cuando sea algebraica mente
difícil de resolver una ecuación puedes
re expresar o replantear tu problema en
una forma que sea más sencilla de
resolver puedes de expresar esto como
dos funciones que al graficar las puedas
aproximar su punto de intersección y te
dé una aproximación a la solución de tu
ecuación que fue exactamente lo que
hicimos aquí obtuvimos que la solución
es aproximadamente
1.66